expression my mother often uses that you
do the right things for the right
reasons
and you live with the consequences
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk a
really exciting day for me
because i admire the gentleman that i
will be interviewing quite a bit and
have for a very long time and
we're we spent two seconds getting to
know each other talking of course
football and we'll get into that in a
minute
um but as many of you know who follow my
content i haven't done a whole lot of
interviews lately and
to be frank i think that uh interacting
with all of you and answering your
questions has been really fruitful and
i want to save the interviews on the
podcast
for special occasions one that excites
me or one that i think can
disproportionately bring value to the
audience and
this showman hits on both fronts so
without further ado i'd like to
introduce arthur blank
to the show i will let this uh
prestigious gentleman
introduce himself because i'm curious to
hear how he positions himself these days
and he's got a new book out and i know
how
how much my audience has enjoyed getting
to know authors
uh around books and have been big
supporters so i hope
the vayner nation can climb some amazon
and barnes noble's ratings and uh things
of that nature so
excited for the new book good company so
arthur how are you
i'm uh i'm fine it's an honor to uh
to chat with you for a little bit um the
other the other thing which we share and
we should probably share a lot of things
in common but we
we both came from queens that's right
and um so i have that
um you know that diversity and that life
experience in my
in my background but uh today i uh you
know i co-founded the home depot in
1979 the first stores and left in 2001
and we were the
second largest retailer in the world at
that time and
today it's the company has a book value
or
capital value i should say close to 300
million 300 billion dollars
and i transitioned into a variety of
other things um to the atlanta falcons
which you mentioned atlanta united our
major league soccer team
we operate the pga tour superstores
which is the largest scout for retailer
in america today
uh we operate several guest ranches in
montana
rated number one in the western part of
the country and we have a very
active and um philanthropic
family foundation so we're involved in a
lot of things and i think the beauty of
the book
and the essence of the book is that all
the values that we cultivated and
developed at home depot
for 23 years and now being shepherded
along beautifully by craig meniere and
their whole team
are the same values we put in place in
all of these different industries
in different settings different
geographies with fans
customers and guests all three of them
through our associates and connected to
the communities that we live in
and really the emphasis of the stories
and the thoughts throughout the book is
that
you can't have both profitability and
emphasis on the people side of the
equation in fact
if you're going to have um gonna really
going to achieve both at high levels
you need to uh you need to achieve both
you need to put emphasis on both of them
and one feeds the other very strongly so
uh it's a great book
not because i wrote it it's not really
about me but it's about these values
which we think are transportable
to virtually every business for-profit
or non-profit as the case may be
arthur i think this is where you know we
share a lot of perspective
i you know to me i call my vayner x my
universe i call it the honey empire
you know i have enormous ambitions you
know i i'd like to match
the accomplishments you have especially
because i want to buy the new york jets
and and and
but i also think that you can do that
with honey over vinegar i
i'm uncomfortable actually in deep
negativity
and and bad human traits and
you know i i i enjoy the part of my
career right now
because i have a lot of kids watching me
on these social networks and words
you know i started a wine brand it's
called empathy you know like
these things to me and you were
pioneering it before
i think people are confused that you
don't have to kill people or be mean
to be a successful business person i
think that's what i heard in your
opening statement
yeah well i i think not not only uh you
don't have to be that way i think it's
it's counter being successful
i agree and i'm measuring success really
in uh in
in two ways uh one is the financial
results which obviously is what most
people
conventionally would think of but also
in terms of
having purpose in life and uh you don't
have to be
someone like a deepak chopra who's a
good friend and endorsed the book and
read it
but um but you you have to understand
that you know
young people to take today particularly
i think
are striving for more purpose than i
think
they've ever ever done so in the past an
example and you're probably familiar
with this
is dr laurie santos uh who also read the
book and endorses it
who has a professor of psychology
university she started this course as
you probably know
on on on happiness happiness lab because
30 40 kids
said to it has to be more in life than
just this has to be more in life than
just making money etc and being
successful
she now uh as many of your listeners may
be aware she now
um she teaches that class to a quarter
of the student body of yale university
at a time
one quarter it's the largest enrollment
class i've ever had in the history of
years
205 years old it's now available to
everybody online so
pass it on to your listeners too it's
available online and it's done
beautifully so
arthur let me ask a question i'm
starting to interrupt but i want to get
so much out of you in this short time
together
what kind of kid were you like i'm very
i'm very very curious well i was very
competitive i was very competitive i
i you know and my focus really growing
up was sports i played football ran
track
played baseball you know for my high
school and
i was really good athlete i would say
i'm not good enough to go to the next
level
and i pretty much banged myself up my
junior year playing football we had a
great football team at stuyvesant high
school in new york
uh my junior year we won all of our
games
average score was like 44-6 i think
something like that
so we uh we had a really good team we
had a bunch of uh
young men that went on and got full
scholarships and played well and
collegiately but
um i've always been competitive where
you're p
you know so i don't know if you know
this because i i know you knew it sounds
like you knew the queen's part but i was
actually born in belarus in the former
soviet union
and i yeah and i came over in 78
when they let when they let a small
amount of jews out when israel in
america you might remember this jury
was able to get you know so that that is
you know my origin story and i've always
felt
and i tell a lot of my contemporaries in
their late 30s early 40s that are
business men and women that are
sometimes
when we get into these dinners i'm like
you have to understand i'm far more like
your grandfather
than i am like you because i lived in a
studio apartment with
you know seven family members like i
remember that this is not my you know
i think that you you grew up in a
queen's
in your in your years hey was it your
parents or your grandparents that came
over from the old country
it was my grandparents right so so to me
i'm curious how much do you think the
environment
that you grew up in lent itself to the
acceleration
of your competitiveness because it's
obviously a dna game
but it's also clearly an environment
game yeah and looking at your
timing of when you're growing up in
queens i'm always romantic about that
era
as a historian because i think a lot of
good tips on shoulders and ruggedness
that led to great
success to your point both happy and
altruistic and you know kind of
financial there's a lot of men and women
that came from that era and
you know there's something in the water
is something you hear a lot
i feel like there's something in the
water for those italian jews
irishmen immigrants kids and grandkids
of immigrants in that new york at your
era
well you know that's a really good point
and i i think
um you know i think yes there was
something in the water and i think the
water
in that point was going going through
the experience of your parents coming
through
at ellis island settling in lower
manhattan often without anything to
speak up financially
uh you're working uh any number of jobs
to just
you know to just maintain you know a
sense of of keeping
uh family together and supporting each
other and and so i think you know the
notion of
overcoming that form of adversity if you
will or those challenges wouldn't say
adversity but challenges
i think we've really done done
beautifully by our families and uh
so i think in my family you know given
the fact i lost my
dad when i was only 15 years old he was
44 and
and so i think that that puts some you
know emphasis on my mind
another another connection point for us
and realized my father
at the same ages on both his father and
himself
lost his dad at 15 when my grandfather
was going down yeah
that's amazing well that's real
connection yeah
um so you know my mother my mother went
into his business without any
background that he had started in his
early 40s and uh she ran it beautifully
and eventually sold it and
so i think you know the notion of
pushing through challenges
looking for challenges looking for
opportunities to
to enhance to make the world a better
place if you will
my mother was a woman of principle i
think that became very important to me
at an early age and
expression my mother often uses that you
do the right things for the right
reasons
and you live with the consequences i i
think that's
you know i think that stayed with me for
many years and and drives a lot of the
the cultural aspects of what we talk
about in the book
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop you there
because i think when people ask me why
i have this honey empire thing blah blah
blah and i literally say
my mom my mom you know first of all i
share her dna so being nice
and kind and by the way i'm
uncomfortably competitive which actually
confuses people
actually that's a good question arthur
since you're you know
many years in success ahead of me on
this journey but i'm very curious
did you know and maybe it's the climate
we live in today because obviously
you know there it's always a timing
thing but
do you feel that people actually confuse
individuals that are competitive and
don't realize that
it's actually very easy to coexist with
kindness and competitiveness
but that sometimes competitiveness
especially in the heat of the moment
manifests to something that seems a
little bit more aggressive and not
naturally kind
and that confuses some outside observers
yeah i think it can but you know
your people um that i have great respect
for
um even making um
being as firm as they want to be making
the points they need to make
and strong as need to make it have
always found a way to do it
with with a degree of kindness and i go
back to
dr king two of his closest disciples uh
are close friends of mine one just
passed away john lewis yes
who was a you know a very close friend
and andy young who still lives in
atlanta two of the closest
to dr king and you know another
gentleman who wrote the phone in the
book jimmy carter
one of the kindest thoughtful uh most
caring people i've met in my life
and yet extremely competitive i mean
there's a story i talk about in the book
when we're climbing
climbing rocks together with an outward
bound course and um
his wife got up on top sooner than he
did
so i said you know mr president this is
after you left office
have you had enough i remember looking
at me sweaty sweaty sweaty eyes
everything
he said no he said i'm not we're not
leaving until i make this climb
and he did but you know so i i think you
can have both
no it's funny i agree but the way i
think about it obviously
and you a lot of people don't realize
how much success you have in uh
soccer proper football with your club
there too i do think the physical
manifestation
versus the boardroom communication style
does have a little bit of a tweak
right i see a lot of people to your
point that i see do a great job
in the boardroom managing their people
managing up down left and right
but then you get them in a pickup
basketball and they're throwing an elbow
in your chest because that's where you
get to see the
physical manifestation yeah yeah i i
think that
you know i i can relate to that and i
would say this
i was always very competitive and i
still am today i'm i don't like to lose
anything i remember um a brief story i
remember my wife and i
uh when the first first year we got
married we played scrabble
we played 24-24 the first one who uh
who won 25 games is going to be the
champion of scrabble
and i told this to us our team a
football team in 2001 they asked me
are you competitive so we played the
last game of scrabble with no time
limits on it
i lost that we were married 27 years we
never played another game of scrabble
i love you already so you know i mean
you know i don't like to lose but uh you
know
anyway but it's um what uh remind me is
the book out
or about it's out it's out
it was published september 15th and it's
out available in
all the books you can imagine what
what has been the most surprising you
know for me
i've written five business books and one
wine book i grew up in the wine business
of all things my dad had a liquor store
in new jersey that i transformed to an
early.com wine business
what the one thing i liked through all
six of those process
was the feedback because you're in your
book
for a period of time the the feedback
that you didn't see coming
i think this would be a fun question
that might have some insights
any any feedback from
a random email or somebody close to you
of an observation from the book that you
had not thought of that you appreciated
or that kind of
has caught your attention so far here in
a couple weeks that it's been out well
i think it's a great question i don't
know but i'll be seeking the answer okay
because i really and i've told people
who've read it or you know halfway
through it or whatever
i i'm really interested in uh in their
critique of the book i mean
you know as you've experienced when you
write one of these books and you go
through them after a while you you
fall in love with what you're writing
and you you finally sign off on it's the
best product you can produce at that
time etc and it tells your story
whatever story it may be but
you know how other people see it uh and
there are a handful of people that i
have
deep respect for that i'm interested in
getting their feedback and i'm sure
they'll give it to me too so
uh what um do you look at this
as a legacy piece because you feel like
that one of your natural talents
and i by the way i'm such a buyer of an
important thing you said
i have literally told every cfo
overly financially driven friend of mine
because i tend to even though i have
these big ambitions
obsessed with the process more than
actually the dollars that come along
with it
i've i've told them all the time i
believe that kindness actually is a
practical financial impact and i was my
heart was smiling and my brain was
smiling when you said the same
do you view this as a legacy piece for
you because you do think that it is a
it's a nuance that comes natural to you
that you've executed on and your
partner's at depot and and
do you feel like this is something that
you think is misunderstood
is the way yeah i yeah i do gary but i
but it's interesting because um uh it
was just you know last year 2019
probably a lot of the people that you're
referring to or maybe some of the people
referring to were part of the business
roundtable so in 2019
after 50 years of being in business that
roundtable
they changed their charter to saying our
our emphasis is not just going to be
return on
on on profitability it's going to be
people planet and profits all balanced
out
keeping in mind our associates and our
suppliers and our communities as well so
even that group of 192 ceos
even they've changed their emphasis and
it goes back you know milton friedman a
great economist wrote
you know book 50 years ago and said the
purpose of a corporation is to make
money for shareholders period
that's the end of the discussion today i
think you know
uh the view is different it's changing i
think and
that's really the emphasis of the book
is that i think you can have both
and i think you need both one enhances
the other it's not that you have to have
one or the other or one takes away from
the other
the beauty of a weighted barbell on both
ends that is balanced
is that it's equally weighted and i
think the story in this book is that
those
good values that based on human
relationships between who you're serving
who's doing the serving and the
communities you're living in and
profitability
are all all equally important at the end
of the day you want people
that work for you gary or people that
have worked for me to feel like
this is not just about making money it's
about i'm
i'm committing myself to an organization
that's making a difference in the world
it's making the difference of other in
other people's lives
and your following comes because those
people are listening to you because
because they because they believe in
what you're sharing with them is making
a difference in
in their lives to your point i'm
reversal engineering
bringing value on for them not myself
which i understand the karma of that it
has a practical impact and giving me
opportunity
for myself it's not super complicated
it's good builds on good
exactly right and that's you know when
you develop that kind of
you know relationship with who you're
serving so like in our stadium as an
example we haven't had a couple of good
years for our soccer team has been
superlative since we've
uh you know started the franchise three
and a half years ago
last couple of years a football team has
been you know very average compared to
the jets may be better
but not a whole lot better but not a
whole lot better by the way
you know by the way i'm sorry to
interrupt you i know we were trying to
do this a couple weeks ago
schedules we when i you know i don't
want to even bring this up because i
know how spicy i get after
i i was watching your football game this
sunday and i said
oh boy this is you know this dude is
gonna be
you know because because that one that
one hurt
oh it really hurt i mean it's just you
know when you have that kind of lead you
have to go back
i mean you your listeners probably don't
want to know this the just may hold a
similar record but
you have to go back to 1933 when the
team scored 39 points had zero turnovers
and lost the game so and
on top of that we had that we had
tournament ratio of of plus three
so i mean anyway i we we've already
moved on we got to play the bears next
sunday
coaches players we've all moved on we've
got to get on that real quick i want to
jump in here on this
very curious what has there been
a challenge transitioning to sports
coming from the business world where
it feels to me and this is almost the
most selfish question in podcast history
because i'm starting to mentally prepare
for hopefully my great dream coming true
you know
it you know i'm already thinking through
things like in my business life
i feel like i have more control than i
do with
injuries in football you got to give a
gm or a coach
some breathing room even when
intuitively you're concerned
has just out of sheer curiosity
how does one find the balance of being
able to control things for example
somebody has a great interview with you
i don't know how many coaches you've had
in your ownership
but you've been through this i've been
through this and even in my young career
it feels right right up to the second
and then literally a week later you're
like uh oh
you know i'm sure you've seen that with
players kids you've drafted i've seen it
my brother left my company and started
an nfl representation business
as a matter of fact uh we we have uh we
have foyer
vayner sports company represents your
player that
forced three [ __ ] fumbles and [ __ ]
fumbles in one game this last week
went to neil by the way yeah you're very
smart guy and a terrific person
and a obviously great player probably
coach quinn said it might be the best
maybe the best 17 minutes the
linebacker's ever had
by the way even more fun we also we also
represent keith
uh beef uh the fullback uh and so and so
so very nice man very nice so we you
know
i watch a lot of your team because of
that you know
tell me what it took to calibrate the
inability to act
when you wanted to act which i think is
slightly different than running a
company where
then you have to sometimes wait as well
but not to the same level of degrees i
think when there's a
sports franchise because of so many
other variables in it
well i you know it's really interesting
i think that
one one good piece of advice i got from
robert kraft the one's the patriots he's
a good friend of mine
and uh when i when i bought the team in
2001 we had breakfast together i was in
new york with
commissioner tagner going through my
owner's orientation and
he said why don't you hang around one
day have breakfast tomorrow with robert
and i said i'd be happy to do that so i
did and one of the things robert said to
me was that you're going to hear from a
lot of people that the nfl is a
different business you're going to hear
that says
run the nfl run your franchise just like
you run the home depot and you're going
to be successful now the one thing
that's different
two things are different one of which
you pointed out when somebody has an
injury god forbid if matt ryan gets hurt
you see them from different places you
know the team's in a different place
whereas in business matt ryan breaks a
leg he gets a cast on and comes to work
the next day so you're not losing him
that's right
the the other thing which is different
is that um the amount of media coverage
uh which is involved with the nfl and
therefore all 32 teams is incredible so
when robert said that to me i said well
you know home depot we took the company
public or
second largest retail in the world today
and you know et cetera
he looked at me and he's and he winked
like you know sometimes you do i don't
know if you have any children gary yeah
if you have a young child sometimes they
they won't understand something
she'll say at some point in your life
you'll understand this and that's
but remember i said it so he's turned
out to be right the media coverage on
the nfl is incredible
um and so you know other than those two
things
it's really and that's the beauty of the
book it talks about
football soccer guest ranching
philanthropy
golf retailing same values apply you
have the same kind of successes
available
and my own enjoyment
where do you sit you know obviously so
much of my career
is going to be built it looks like on
the foundation of modern communication
right i was an early investor at
facebook and twitter and
my communications company spends a lot
of time on that in the most ironic of
ironic things i was on a call this
morning
for the first time by the way in the 11
years that i've run my company with home
depot because we've just
won a significant amount of business
with scott's miracle grow and we were
having a business meeting
so it's been a home depot kind of day oh
great um
when i i was just curious and we were
having very progressive conversations
around
hulu and and amazon prime commercials
versus network television
commercials we've already seen the nfl
start to dabble with amazon right
there's a lot going on there
just out of general curiosity you the
human what is your relationship
with the social networks and digital
have you know obviously
you know it comes supernatural to the
six-year-olds
but it's very interesting to see like do
you do you have a linkedin account do
you have a facebook account do you
did any of your you know kids or
grandkids get you on tick-tock like
where
where is you where are you the man on
your media consumptions on your phone
and maybe even a little on tv
are you a netflix guy have you started
going into those environments yeah i
i am i mean i enjoy watching a lot of
the products produced today on
television uh in terms of netflix and
and uh and amazon products etc are
outstanding
um i i have social media instagram and
uh
and facebook i don't post anything but i
really have them i told my kids some
years ago
um i have six children so my youngest
are two that are 19 but i told them
about
six or seven years ago when i went on
social media i told them at dinner time
that i was going to do that and just you
know be able to follow them so you're
smiling but
at the time my daughter my twin brother
looked across the table said
max his name is max her name is kylie
she said do you have any idea what that
means
because you know max was like he said
okay she said that means dad's gonna be
following us following all of our posts
we won't be able to say
this that and the other thing so you
know i have it today because i
i do follow my kids and i'll follow some
other close friends and they're
you know they're follow any of the
players on your soccer football team
just out of control
but you know i follow people like jay
shetty i follow deepak i i
chopper they're both very good friends i
you know there's some other people
uh simon sinek i follow i mean there are
a lot of
people that i do follow i'll follow you
in the future
i would definitely tell you if you i
will all right because you're covering
the kind of things and have the kind of
personality that i would i would like to
learn from
so i i think you know opportunities to
learn from it i mean
to me there's a story i tell in the book
which you know you
may have picked up you may not have when
we had an opportunity to participate in
esports
and um you know it's a situation i mean
we're a private company we're not a
public company etc
and they came in and our management team
had already decided
they really wanted to do this they
wanted to participate in it they came
with their final presentation the
marketing folks came in
and they presented it and one of the
slides was a picture of a young man
who uh had made as i remember some
ungodly amount of money was like
500 000 bucks he was like 12 or 14 years
old
but they said he said he practices 10
hours a day 10 12 hours a day
to be able to be competitive at the
level he's at so
when they left the room you know the
presenting team
and our management team was only there i
said we're not going to do this
and and they said why are we not going
to do it i said there's nothing to do
with our business has to do with our
values i said
i mean i don't want to i don't want to
encourage young people
honestly to sit in front of technology
10-12 hours a day when i think they
should be
outside and they should be enjoying
nature enjoy playing with each other
with a lot of
structure time or unstructured time
whatever it may be but i don't think
it's to their best interest long term i
i do
think you know and you may or may not
agree with this but
you know i think gary that the level of
connectivity that we have today
in the united states or throughout the
world is at an all-time high
and it's only going to get more so but
the level of neighborhood
that exists today in the world is at an
all-time low
and i think and i think back to the way
you and i were raised in queens
the environment we were raised in we
were nurtured in a community
uh both in an apartment i had four
family members living in
one tiny apartment you had eight you
lived in a community everybody supported
each other everybody
came together etc we need more of that
in this country well
to me to me i think there's first of all
from a value filter standpoint i
couldn't agree with you more
i think my take to your point were
excuse a little bit different
first of all the admiration i have for
people
i mean the amount of money i have left
on the table
because i need to feel good about it is
extraordinary
and it is the single and i'm going to
say this very clearly it is the single
thing
that i'm most grateful for it's just a
nice feeling
there's there's no payday interesting
enough for me to feel that feeling as a
matter of fact it's going to lead to a
different question i wanted to ask you
desperately i just want to get in my
mind what i would say arthur is what
i've been able to
discover because i've been so deep in
the trenches and i think like anything
there's a great uh russian saying
it's basically means everything's at its
best when it's balanced
so i think balance is something but who
defines balance
parents society there's all those
variables i will say that people
underestimate the nature of community
that
is built digitally and the expanding of
other views the counterpoint to that is
especially in political times like this
people start going only into places
where they hear affirmation of their
points of view so
there's a whole lot here this is i think
it's a four-hour dinner conversation
in itself yeah let me let me segue
somewhere
let me segue somewhere that i'm very
passionate about
i'm enjoying something recently that i
think about when i think about good
company which is
my inability to be candorous
in my youth as a manager and leader
because i liked happy and good and honey
so much
that i would kind of swallow
micro little transgressions
unfortunately though they would
ultimately lead to
enough little drops where i would either
at my worst
shock and surprise someone and fought in
their firing
and then make myself feel better by
saying how didn't they realize they
stunk
and didn't take on accountability over
the last two to three years
i would say i was on a two out of ten
when it came to candor as a leader
because i overval and it led to as you
can imagine this is gonna make sense to
you led to entitlement
and a lot of things that i had to work
through i think i'm in 6.5 land right
now
with an eye towards eight or nine and
i'm excited about that
in your journey to get you to a place of
these incredible accomplishments
and to be able to write a book like good
company
what part of the formula do you think
you have to
work on the most and get the reps in
versus what came extremely natural to
you that rounded out your ability to
execute good company
well i i would say as it relates to the
first
point that you were making you know i i
i'm a
a prostate cancer survivor and um
i just got another psa and was zero um
so i'm blessed
but but um but i would say you know like
cancer
uh when you see it you need to deal with
it seriously you need to deal with it
early if not it spreads
so i think when you're dealing with
human behavior
uh within an organization when you see
a bad behavior you need to address it
you need to take it on seriously it
doesn't mean you fire anybody but it
means that you
you know you address it seriously yeah
and you know because if not it is going
to spread and it's not going to spread
just with that person but it'll spread
to other people
so the expression of bad apple you know
that part of the honey empire was easy
the part was
i needed to learn a cadence to your
point where i would cut the cancer every
time
it's why i've had what i've had over
these 25 years
the process of getting to the cutting
was something that i was short on
i didn't do it in a way that i feel
great about in hindsight
and i'm trying to build towards well i
think you know i think
i think that that usually comes because
it means somebody
you know the whole notion of cinco
swimming you know in in business i don't
believe in
you know there's nothing worse than
watching somebody uh die from drowning
so if you want to put somebody in a sink
or swim situation make sure they're
properly trained make sure they can swim
make sure they can see the shore
make sure you can throw them a lifeguard
if you if a life jacket rather
if you need to so you know uh
you you really want to train people get
put in the best
best place they can be for success and
and try to make sure they have all the
tools they
they need for that you know if you reach
a point i would say with anybody
that despite all that they just don't
get it don't fit in don't get your
values don't want to leave it
so it's not you really in many in my
experience is that you're doing them a
favor
it's no fun for you to have to beat them
over the head for the next 10 years and
tell them they're
constantly doing the wrong thing and
they don't get it and they don't get it
you know made they just don't fit into
your culture so you do it in a kind
way in a caring way you let them go you
let them move on
to find a different organization that
fits more with the way they choose to
operate
so when i ask you the biggest growth of
people that
you know because this is we're getting
into very
fun territory of me around emotional
intelligence and self-awareness and
things that really matter right um
if i just say to you think of the people
that you've seen grow the most
through your years from pre-depot let
alone depot to today
does it automatically go in your mind
you think of like carol or a susie or a
rick or
john you know like it's pretty it's
pretty powerful to see
that kind of emotional growth no yeah
yeah it is and i
and i would tell you that you know um
the the hallmark to the success of home
depot
it was built on you know products
assortment service level
product knowledge etc etc but the truth
and matter is to get to 2200 stores
where they are today
it's really built on just one thing and
that's understanding
the culture and living the culture i'll
tell you one brief story that when
mckinsey was writing a book on the war
for talent
um their partner in chicago the senior
partner in chicago rachel partner
came to visit me last after we
interviewed 200 of our associates in
canada
in the united states and in chile we're
operating stores there as well and he
said you know i've talked to 200
associates
a lot of engineers cashiers sales people
store managers
district managers presidency divisions
merchants etc
and every single one of them talks about
the culture
exactly the same way they don't use the
same words like it's memorizing just
repeating it
but they understand the essence of it
and they're living it he said i don't
know how you do that i've never met a
company
anywhere and all of our mckinsey
experience that was able to able to do
that
and i think that's the essence of what
makes us successful
at home depot and what makes all of our
businesses successful today is that
the price to get into the game of moving
ahead and being a leader being a manager
is that you have to understand and lead
and be an ambassador for the culture of
that
of all of our businesses which we
expressed there in your own culture
so in your case gary you know it means
that you know sometimes the people are
the best technicians the best this is
that you can hire the best of those
things but you can't always hire
somebody and train somebody to be the
best of
the culture that you want to reflect in
your organization
right arthur um
how competitive um this is a fun
question for me
how competitive were you in seeing how
well the book was going to do
well you know i to be honest with you i
i you know all the
all the all the proceeds are being
donated to the national uh
civil rights museum in atlanta which i'm
proud of it's a great place and
good news arthur i definitely didn't
think this was a financial exercise
it's not but but winners winners win
and i know that you didn't need i'm sure
there were some buddies you've had
written business books that you wanted
to sell one more copy you know what i
only care about one thing honestly
that the book gets out in the hands of
as many people as it can and primarily
if i had to choose if you pressed me and
you might you know you pressed me well
which population i would say the younger
population
the people your your listeners the
people are going to be
thinking about how do i live life with a
purpose how do i run a business with a
purpose
how do i connect not just myself and my
family and my own circle of love
but to the greater need of serving
humanity in a broad sense
and you know i feel strongly that young
people today
are pressing on those questions more and
more
and i think we're blessed by having the
younger population that's doing that
so i would encourage i mean you that
that's who you listeners are
and and i would i would encourage them
continue to press that way
and you know they pick up the book or
trade it amongst themselves amongst 10
people so only one is sold but 10 read
it
that's all i care about is they read it
do they understand it
they understand they can have that
balance in life where they feel like you
know
life is being fulfilling to them and
they're getting confused between their
work and their play
you know that whole zen philosophy is
that you don't go to work you got to
play every day
and you know that's kind of what we we
try to we try to
uh relate to you know i'm going to have
her
who set this up connect me with some of
your book people i i think there's some
really fun
gamification you can do in social that
allows people to act on good behavior
to win a copy of the book that i think
would probably
make you very happy because you'd win on
two fronts there'd be good put into the
world
and another human would consume it and
so i i got a question
when you were just talking that i want
to share with you please
thank you that'd be a blessing for me
thank you arthur i you know i
really really don't want to go here
because even though you mentioned him as
a friend
as you can imagine as a new york jets
fan that has watched every single snap
since 1982
i have an uncomfortably difficult
situation with the new england patriots
this is something we also share you know
that
what what can we learn from a moment
like that super bowl that must have
hurt quite a bit it did you know um
first of all it's a you know it's open
certainly a good question um
you know when you're leading 28 to three
in the middle of third quarter you you
you almost think there's almost no way
to lose the game um
i mean i really wasn't the kind of
person yeah that's right you know to me
i'm such a cynical jets fan no i am too
if you're 49
three with two minutes left i'm still
yeah i am
i i am i am as well so i even though
it's 28 to 3 i wasn't thinking
there was a piece of your brain thinking
about some
excitement but you were pretty locked
into like i'm not very
very locked in and as the game started
to trend in the wrong direction as we
got through the third and fourth quarter
it was interesting my mind went to you
know i'm a father of six a grandfather
of six is that you know how do i
how do i be a source of comfort uh
wisdom counsel
uh support for my family
you know our players our coaches our
fans
um so it went away for myself
to how do i how do i help others get get
through this horrific time
um and that's what my focus was i think
it probably wasn't until maybe a year
later or so that i
i went through the personal you know
pain myself
because i know as you know you're a
football fan 32 teams it's very hard to
get back to the super bowl
it takes a single game elimination the
playoffs so the ball's not around a lot
of things can happen
and uh you know like when i'm at my most
down in business and things that nature
because of
my upbringing and the humble nature and
just the deep pain of generational
suppression in the soviet union
you know i really do care about
something as silly as
football i mean at least it's your team
this is like my my fandom and i get into
a very serious place
i do by the way during covid i had a lot
of friends
we're still in it but like in the early
kind of like first 12 16 weeks i had a
lot of friends going through some pretty
difficult times and i
i really tried to deploy perspective to
them of like just be grateful for what
you have not what you've lost
i remember saying to one friend who was
really struggling
hey you do understand that if covet
started eight weeks earlier kobe bryant
would probably be alive for the next
50 years let's put this into perspective
i understand you're worried about money
i understand you're worried about a
wedding which is very important
but still let's really put this in
perspective do you
tend to go into that place
i tend not to go to the dark place gary
whatever what i tend to do is go to the
place to be
very much like you described i mean i'm
blessed i have you know great family
we have we have great great businesses
um
our golf business as an example which is
just the counter
has taken off i've never seen comp sales
and retail
in my 50 years of retail that we're
experiencing
it's just it's just incredible but you
know to our own associates
with football soccer ranches which we
closed the first time in a hundred years
they've been closed
you know this is 2020. we'll get through
this it's a period of time 2021 will be
fine we'll go through a transition early
2021 and there will be fine going on
and you know keeping perspective all the
things we have blessings over
and everybody has blessings over so i
also know that like our foundation
we've probably granted 40 50 million
dollars
just dealing with um you know emergency
situations due to covert in terms of
food safety and
health and things of that nature we've
helped how many non-profits just get
through this period of time
because these are great organizations
that will do great work in 2021 and
beyond that
and uh so we need to help them get get
through this period of time so
it's it's it's we had a meeting here
last night talking about a variety of
things our leadership team and i said
this is a year you take care of your
friends you take care of your family
you take care of your people that you
care about which is for us as
all of our guests all of our fans you
know all of our customers
and take care of your associates and
then you worry about other things in
2021
um it's just you know that's the
attitude we have to have
it's a tremendous win this interview
arthur thank you for your time
thank you thank you for your time gary i
i appreciate it good good god bless
thank you hey everybody on youtube first
of all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out